men aren't really masculine anymore  they're not leaders anymore the media  tries to put men down a lot there's this  whole idea of self-deprecation and it's  bad to want to do better it's bad to  want to make more money you know all  these traditional masculine traits are  considered toxic masculinity and so  those traits are traits that I like in a  man so it's very difficult because  there's not a lot of men like that and  so I've had this like switch and  mentality in the last few years which  was initially women of the prize we're  the prize I'm the queen bee but now you  realize well actually there's a lot of  beautiful women that's sort of all a  woman needs from like a starting point  occasion needs to be nice nurturing over  a weekend we can teach her but then with  the men they need a lot more that's very  difficult to find unfortunately I have a  lot of amazing male role models in my  life so that UPS the standard even more